[inaudible] joining me today is a leader,
a follower, a reader, or
a writer, a speaker or a
listener. A student, a teacher,
Jocko Willink. Welcome to the
Rubin report. How was that?
I took that right out of the bio.
That's good.
Right out of the Twitter bio
as much viral. Yeah. Yeah.
You're a little bit of everything.
That actually is a pretty good
explanation of you. It actually,
it actually is a pretty
good explanation to me.
I think garden cover those multiple
dichotomies fairly well. Yeah,
that would probably explain why
you've written roughly 37,000 books.
How many books have you written?
I mean,
I normally only put one book on the table.
We put four here.
I've written so far I've written three
adult books and three kids books.
I've got another kid's book coming out
in the Spring and I've got another adult
book coming out,
going head to head with Jordan
Peterson in January of 2020 Oh,
oh yeah. I probably will be on
tour with him for that book.
That means that we're going
to be in competition. Okay,
well bring it all right.
We'll see. We'll see. Okay, so nice to,
uh, to not actually have to compete with,
with y'all. Yeah. What do you,
do you feel like you're in
competition with anyone that's,
that's an interesting place to start off.
Well that's,
I guess there's a dichotomy there
too because I don't feel like I'm in
competition with anyone and
I feel like I'm competent.
I'm trying to touch just sort
of in my nature to just compete.
But no, I mean in this
world that I'm in right now,
I don't really feel like
I'm competing with anyone.
I feel like I'm just
kind of doing what I do,
talking about what I like to talk about,
writing about what I like to write about
and hanging out with cool people most
of the time. Yeah. Pretty
good. Pretty good. All right.
Well I think 99% of my audience knows
who you are and knows a lot about you.
But for the people that don't,
and by the way, I should say,
right before we started,
I was saying we have been trying to
coordinate this for about 27 years.
Right? I mean a long time,
which is kind of funny. I mean,
it really says, it's like,
well, we're two people that are, that
are busy. Yeah. And it was hard to,
hard to really make this happen, but for
the people that know nothing about you,
tell me a little bit about your history.
I was born and raised in a small,
New England town. I was
a rebellious kid. My
best way to rebel as a kid coming from
a small new England town was to join the
military. So I joined the
military after high school.
I spent 20 years in the military and
when I retired from the military,
I started taking the things that I learned
from the military and teaching them
to civilian companies
and civilian leaders.
And eventually that turned into a book
and a podcast and all this other stuff.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit more about what
you were like that made you want to go
into the military. What was that
rebellious kid or whatever that was? Yeah.
You know,
I just grew up in a little new England
town and there was a lot of hippies and
just kind of kids like that running
around and smoking pot and whatever.
And I really wasn't into
that. And so, you know,
I got to think a lot of kids when they
rebel as kids because all kids rebel,
a lot of kids repelled by drinking or they
do drugs or whatever they're gonna do.
And I went in the other direction was
like into hardcore music and eventually
said,
Oh yeah,
I'm just going to join the military
because that's what I'm going to do. Yeah,
it's funny when you talk about it and
it almost sounds like you're slightly
dismissing it, but you had a pretty
good storied career as a navy seal.
Yeah, no, I grew up in the seal
teams. I went right in the navy,
right in the seal teams and that's
where I spent my whole adult life.
And it was an incredible experience.
Worked with a bunch of awesome people
and got to do things that I had dreamed
about doing since I was a little kid.
Well,
what should we know about like the life
of a navy seal that you don't get in the
movies or, or however else we just
sort of imagined these lives to be.
I would say the biggest thing to remember
is that that people in the seal teams
and people in the military
in general, they're people,
they're just normal people.
They go home, they got
wives, they got kids,
they're trying to live a normal life
and then their job requires them to do
things that are very normal.
And so they, you know, for me,
I kind of learned to compartmentalize
what I was doing in the military and when
I'd come home,
and I always,
I tell this to police
officers and firefighters and
military guys today don't,
when you get home, don't
bring your uniform home.
Don't wear your uniform home.
Like physically change your,
take your uniform off, leave
it at work, put on your,
your civilian clothes when you
go home and be a civilian. The,
how hard is that though, once you're
sort of in that locked mindset,
which obviously has so much to do with
the things that you write about and why
your message actually is working
and helping people. You say,
how hard is it l it can be hard,
it can be hard. Uh, you know,
cause you've got one life that you're
living where decisions are really
consequential and then you've got your
regular life that you're living and
things aren't that they aren't
as consequential. You know,
I had a situation where I was at work
and there was a lot of stuff going on at
work. They were, they were
redeploying people to Afghanistan.
There was big decisions that
were being made at work.
And I remember I came home from
work one day and like I said,
tried to try to leave my work at work.
But I'm sitting there thinking about how
all this stuff is going to unfold and
my wife, you know, I got home and
my wife cause I can't believe this.
And I was like, what happened is, is
everything okay? And she says, you know,
the, no, it's not okay. The
Disney on ice is the same night.
Some other events for the kids. And
I'm just thinking, Hey, if that's,
if that's the biggest worries my wife has,
then that's a positive thing,
then life's pretty good. Yeah.
Life's pretty good. Yeah.
So how quickly did you realize that
you wanted to sort of bring these ideas
about personal responsibility and sort
of owning your life and all that into
sort of that world, the world where
Disney on ice matters? Yeah, it's,
I was about six months from retiring.
I had a friend that was the CEO
of a big company and he said,
I want you to come and talk
to my executives about combat
leadership. And I said,
hey, sure. You know, sounds, sounds cool.
So I went and did it and when I got,
and I don't think he really
knew what to expect, you know,
because I'm looking like a knuckle
dragger and I'm at least a good portion.
I actually am a knuckle dragger and so
we bring me in to talk and I thought,
I think he was maybe thinking, I tell
some cold war stories and that'd be,
that'd be great. But I actually
started talking about how you lead.
And when I got done,
he came up to me and said,
I want you to do this for every division
that I have in my company. And I said,
well, you know, I'm retiring. And
he said, well, I'll give you money.
And I said,
okay.
So I started working with all the
different divisionals and at one of those
division meetings, the CEO of the parent
company was there. And when I got done,
he came up to me and said,
I want you to come and talk to all my
CEOs for all these companies that I own.
And he owned like 45 or 50 companies.
So I went and did that.
And when I went and talked to
those companies, of course,
then a bunch of those CEOs
came up to me and said, hey,
I want you to come and talk to my company.
So that's kind of the,
the way that it started and it didn't
take me very long at all. I mean,
it actually was the very first company,
that first guy that I
talked to when they started,
when that group started telling me
about the problems they were having,
I was sitting there thinking myself,
well,
I solve these problems in seal platoons
when I was training seal platoons.
This is the same thing.
It's leadership. Yeah.
Were you surprised that the big
successful businesses were having such a
leadership crisis?
I was surprised for about five minutes
and then I realized that these are all
human beings. These are the same human
beings that are in a seal platoon,
in an RV company and in a
business and they're all,
they all have the same idiosyncrasies.
They have the same egos,
the same personalities.
You can see it all and when you've
seen it all over and over again,
it becomes pretty evident,
pretty clear when you're looking at it.
And the last job that I had in
the seal teams, I was training,
I was running the seal training
for the west coast seal teams.
And this isn't a training where you
see like the guys carrying the boats on
their heads and carrying logs around
and doing a bunch of pushups and stuff.
The training that I ran was the training
where seals actually learned to go into
combat and fight the enemy and this is
where we really start focusing on combat
leadership.
And so in this training that I ran,
we got to take seal platoons and put
them through really tough training
scenarios, very realistic training
scenarios over and over and over again.
So every night I basically would be
putting a new seal platoon through another
training scenario,
which the next night it will be another
scope and going through this same
training scenario.
And then the next thing would be another
seal between going through the same
training snow.
So you take these different seasons and
what's different about a seal platoon?
What's different about a seal platoon
is really just boils down to the
leadership because we've got 16 seals in
a scope that the guys are basically the
same show. There's some, there's a bell
curve, there's some top end performers,
there's some low on performers
as a bunch of guys in the middle.
So the real variation on their performance
was based almost a hundred percent on
their, on their leadership. In fact,
it was 100% on their leadership.
And so I got to see this and I got to
watch these leadership scenarios on fold
over and over again and
see what leadership things
worked and what didn't work.
And, and so by the time I, I left that
job and entered the civilian sector,
I've watched some random team of leaders
inside of an organization and I said to
myself,
well,
they're strategic messages and
getting down to the front line troops,
they need to communicate this better.
Or Oh,
they're departments
aren't working together.
They need to cover and
move forward together.
Or their mission is way too complex and
that no one has any idea what they're
actually supposed to be doing.
So they need to simplify this or that.
This senior leader is
making all the decisions and
therefore everything's moving
really slow and nothing's
happening at a good rate of speed.
So they need to use decentralized sematic.
And it was just so obvious when I started.
How much of leadership in general do
you think is innate versus learned?
Obviously you're teaching
people to learn part,
but there has to be some element that's an
eight, right? Yeah, there absolutely is.
And there's the,
the analogy that I give, and I don't
play video games, but I've seen it,
but on video games,
there's,
you have a character in a video game
and you'll have a certain level of
intelligence is on a certain level of
strength and a certain level of agility
and those levels are what you get
and then you work with them. Well,
it's the same thing for a
leader and there's different,
there's different characteristics that
you get that are good for leadership,
right? If you're someone
that's really articulate,
that's a great thing to have to be a
good leader because you want the human
beings that you're talking to to
understand what you're actually saying.
So and different people are naturally
more articulate than other people.
It's good to be able to look at complex
problems and be able to simplify them.
Right?
That's a,
that's a very powerful tool to have a
really complex thing to solve and be able
to look at it and say,
okay,
simplify it and then simplify it not only
for yourself so you can decide what to
do, but simplify it for your team so
they understand what to do. That's,
that's a characteristic
that some people have.
The the one that I bring up a
lot because it's very obvious is,
is being loud because if you're
in a leadership position,
you need to be able to
make people hear you.
And some people are born
with a very loud voice.
I was luckily born with a very loud
voice and it's inherited from my genes,
right? And my kids inherited there.
My kids are all can be very loud,
which is sometimes problematic in house,
but if you can't bark a command so that
people can hear you and a machine gun
fight, no one's been able to
do what you ask them to do.
So there's these different characteristics
and you can improve upon them.
So if you're not very articulate,
you can read and you can write and
you can speak and you can become more
articulate. If you are not very
good at simplifying problems,
you can start looking at complex
problems and thinking about how you can
simplify them.
And you can get better at that.
The being loud part is that, there's
definitely a genetic aspect of that.
So sure you can learn to
project your voice more,
but some people aren't very loud,
they're just born that way.
And so what does a person
do in that situation? Well,
what a person does not situation
is when they have to give an order,
they tell one of the loud mouse in their
platoon to tell everyone to get over
this other building now.
And that loud mouth will pass the word.
And so what you do as a leader,
as you find members for your team
that can compliment your weaknesses.
So there are parts that you could
improve and there are parts that you can
improve.
And if you,
the only real impediment to improving is
someone that doesn't have the humility
to say,
you know what,
I think I could work on being
more articulate or you know what?
I think I could work on solving
problems and making them more simple.
Or you know what? I'm not that loud.
And instead of saying, you know what,
that's not a good way to lead and said,
I said, you know what? I'm not that loud,
but Billy over here is loud,
so I'm going to let him put the word
out when it needs to get put out.
But if you're giving out the humility to
do that, you won't improve as a leader.
Have you found those people that even
if you lay out what the right, you know,
skills are that they have to work on or
where their blind spots are, etc. Etc.
That they just can't, whether it's ego
or whatever else that they just can't,
they just, certain people you just
can't get through to. Absolutely.
It's a horrible situation to be in.
And in the seal teams,
those guys will get fired in
the civilian sector. Generally.
Those guys get fired because I mean you,
you,
you go into a company and you've got a
CEO that is not listening to anyone up or
down the chain and not listening to the
board, not listening to subordinates.
How is he going to improve? He's
not going to, and by the way,
why does he need to improve?
He needs to improve because his
company isn't doing well. So,
but this person might think, hey,
you know, I'm great. I don't,
I'm not gonna learn anything from anybody.
I'm just gonna keep doing it my way.
And that guy's not going to stay in
that job because they don't have the
humility to say, you know what, I'm
probably doing some things wrong.
That's why we're not making money.
And so I need to change some of the
things that I'm doing so that we can make
money. But if you don't have that
attitude and you're not humble, yeah,
you'll end up getting fired.
So conversely,
have you seen people that basically had
none of the skills that have been able
to overcome it?
Just through perseverance that just
innately don't have the leadership traits
that don't have, you know, they
don't speak loud, they aren't clear,
they can't make decisions, but just out
of sheer sort of force of will, there's,
there's all these little aspects that
you have you can improve upon right now
you you're not going to take,
I'm not going to lie to you and say you
can take somebody that has no aptitude
for leadership and they're going
to turn into a great leader.
That's probably not going to happen,
but you can't take someone
that has minimal aptitude
for leadership and they can
improve the areas where
they need to improve.
They can compliment themselves with a
team that can cover for the areas where
they're weak and they can end up doing
a great job in a leadership position for
sure. Yeah. So handing
some of this stuff off,
people don't think of that in certain
ways when it comes to leaders,
like they have to do everything
or know everything or something.
But actually hand in some of
this stuff off is, is good.
Delegating actually is good.
Oh yeah, absolutely. Like
for instance, big shocker,
I don't really like doing paperwork a lot,
you know what I mean?
Really it's [inaudible].
I know it might seem odd,
but I always had guys that worked for me.
I'd figured out that guy that was really
good at administrative stuff and there
you go.
Guess what?
He's going to do a bunch of
administrative stuff and that's great.
And so whatever areas of weakness
you have, have some, you know,
get a member of your team,
recruit someone,
bring someone on board that can actually
make these things happen and it'll work
out great.
Yeah.
Are you kind of surprised how much we
need a leadership sort of in society right
now that we seem to have like a
complete dearth of leadership? I mean,
you mentioned Jordan Peterson before.
When I see the message that
he's bringing to these people,
it's really about getting yourself
together, which is the most,
I mean it's very consistent with
your message, but, but there's,
but the people that are coming are sort
of looking for a leader to say that,
that we just don't have, had seemingly
don't have good leaders right now. Do,
do you think that's a fair estimation?
Well, we do have good leaders.
There's plenty of good leaders out
there and I see him all the time in the
business world.
I still work with the military and
there's great leaders inside the military.
There's great leaders inside
of the business world for sure.
There's also always a lack of
leadership. And I mean, I, you know,
on my podcast I'd cover,
I cover books about war
generally first person accounts,
and there's a lack of leadership back
then and there's going to be theirs.
So I don't know if it's
gotten any better or worse,
but the fact of the matter
is that leadership is,
is the hardest thing in the world as far
as I know. It's, it's the hardest thing.
You know, people used to ask me when I,
when I first got out of the military,
what was the most complex, you know,
operation that you would plan on.
Planning operations isn't that big
of a deal. Like here's a bad guy,
here's the assets that we have,
here's what we're going to do
to go take them out. I mean,
this is stuff that generally
it's not that hard to do,
but the hard part is,
is leading human beings.
And so why does it seem like there's that
we need better leadership because you
always need better leadership and because
leadership is so hard to actually do
properly.
Yeah.
Do you think we need some
sort of mandatory military
service to get some of this
through to young people?
I think military service is
great for people. I know it was,
it was great for me and it,
it worked out really well for me,
but I really don't believe in,
in mandatory service because I really
don't believe that it's good for
government to tell people what you need
to do. Yeah, I don't really support that,
but I definitely support and encourage
everyone to go in the reserves, you know,
go join that,
join the army or the Marine Corps,
the Navy Air Force reserves
where you go away for, you know,
six weeks or eight weeks and you kind
of learn what the military is about and
then you do one weekend a month and two
weeks in the summertime for you know,
indefinitely. So I think I have a pretty
good handle on your politics, but do you,
do you even have a label that kind of
works for you politically? Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno. I don't know what the
label, I don't know how they,
I think it'd be pretty hard to label.
If you were just sort of summing
up sort of your political beliefs,
what would you say?
I think that,
I guess a broad statement would be,
I don't think that the government is
the solution to our problems. Yeah.
I think that generally
unleashing individuals to
try and make things happen is
the best way for things to
work. It's, it's consistent
with decentralized command.
Go to talk, talk about in the, in
the first book that I wrote with my,
my brother life is you can't
control everything. You know,
centralized decision making does not work.
It doesn't work on the battlefield,
it doesn't work in business.
It doesn't work with governments.
So that's broadly speaking,
Guy,
I don't think that the government should
control what individuals are doing as
little as possible. Do there have to
be some rules and regulations in place?
Absolutely. But the framework
should be as loose as possible.
Just like if I'm running a seal platoon,
it's not every man for himself.
It's here's our standard
operating procedures,
here's the areas where we
commit to disciplined process.
But then once you understand
those and you know those,
you're allowed to operate freely within
those guidelines to execute the mission.
And that's what works.
That's what makes not just the seal teams.
That's what makes any
good military unit good.
And that's what makes
good businesses good.
Good businesses are good because someone
is micromanaging every single decision.
Good businesses are good because people
broadly understand the direction they're
heading.
They understand that and they're
allowed to move forward as they see fit.
Are you shocked when you
say something like that?
Which obviously I agree with 100% I mean,
all I talk about here is
personal responsibility over
and over that that doesn't
seem to sort of be the kind of flavor
of the day at the moment that this,
if you listen to mainstream media,
it's who are the more, well,
the government should give you this and
we should take from some of them give to
others that there's a more feeling of you.
You are owed something rather
than you got to get something.
You're asking if I'm surprised
by that. Yeah, because it,
because the way you're laying it out,
it's obvious. You know what I mean?
Like I mean that in the best sense, it's
obvious like, yeah, it's your life. Go,
go do something that has value in
and creates real easy answers. No,
I'm not surprised by it at all because
if I come here and offer you something
for free, why would you not want it? Why
would you not want to take it? If I say,
Hey, you can have this house
for free, and you'd say, okay,
that seems like a good deal to
me. Right. And so yeah, sure.
I understand why people think that
sounds like a good idea because it's
something for free and they want to in
their own individual oral, they think,
okay, I do want to take advantage of
this, right. Get something for free.
So it doesn't surprise me at all that
what is unfortunate is if you can't draw
the line between,
hey,
everyone gets everything for free and
there's a price to that that somebody's
going to have to pay.
That's where it becomes a part in some
costs in there somewhere, somewhere. Yeah.
So tell me what it was like
when you started writing,
because that must've been a whole
other ball of wax. You know, it was,
I was actually an English
major in college and I went,
I went to college halfway through my navy
career, started off as an enlisted guy,
went to college and then became an officer
and then went to college eventually.
So, and the reason I was an English
major was because, believe it or not,
when you're an officer in the military
and actually almost any job in the
military, you have to write. Why not
just have to write, you have to read,
you have to understand because you have
to write concept of operations documents
that are going to be pushed up the
chain of command and they're gonna read
through them and ask questions and
and look at the document and try and
comprehend what it is
that you're trying to do.
You've got to write evaluations
for your troops and your,
your troops are getting promoted based
on the evaluations that you, right.
Same with awards.
You've got to write awards.
Same thing was after actions reports.
So if you do an operation
and things don't go well,
you have to be able to articulate and
explain that what happened and then pass
that word on.
So everyone understands now that you're,
you're being given direction.
Verbal direction. Yes, of course.
But you're given written
direction as well.
You're given missions in a written format
or you're given rules of engagement in
a written format written by lawyers.
And I realized while I was
a young enlisted guy, and
then as a junior officer,
what I really need to be able to do is
understand and communicate well up and
down the chain of command. So when
I went to college I said, yeah,
I want to learn English, I want to get
good at it. And so that's what I did.
And so obviously I did a bunch of writing
and a ton of reading when I was in,
when I was an English major in college.
And then when I was in the military is
writing, you're writing all the time.
And then when,
when when I got out and I was working
with these companies and grew really
quickly,
and that's why my,
my buddy who was one of
the platoon commanders that
worked for me in the battle
of Ramadi, Leif Babin, he, he
was getting out of the navy too.
And I, you know, as we started I started
need some cover and I said, hey man,
you want to want to jump
in and get some of this?
And he was all on board and
then as we started doing this,
people would always say, Hey, do you
have this stuff written down anywhere?
Do you have a document you can give us?
And so we eventually wrote it
down and then that's how the,
that's how the first book came.
Yeah.
Can you lay out a little bit about
the battle of Ramadi? You basically,
you sort of wrote the plans.
The person that led the battle of Amati
that I was in was a guy named Shawn
Mcfarland who was a colonel at the time.
He retired as a general,
just a super smart,
incredibly competent and,
and great leaders,
have great leader and key came in
with, so I had 40 seals with me, right?
I had 40 sales with me
and 60 support people.
Colonel Mcfarlane had 5,600 man armored
brigade that we supported and we helped
them. We work together in the
battle of Ramadi, vicious fighting.
Very tough battle.
And really took a city that was completely
controlled by the insurgence in 2005
2006 and by early 2007 it was
almost completely pacified.
So it was a, it was
incredible. It was incredible,
incredible turnaround and an incredible
testament to the capability of the US
armed forces.
Do you guys pay any attention to what's
going on politically back home when
you're halfway across the
world? Yes, absolutely.
You have to pay attention to
what's going on politically.
Back [inaudible] especially like at
this time when we deployed to Ramadi,
so it's 2005 2006 this is smack dab in
the middle of the rising negative public
opinion about the war in Iraq.
It's also where we had our own government
officials here in America that we're
saying this is unwinnable, this is
another Vietnam. This is a quagmire.
We shouldn't be there to
bring everyone home. So yeah,
you absolutely hear those things
and that's not good. That's not,
it's not a positive thing.
It's not a positive thing to have your
own government officials in America
saying that you cannot win.
And meanwhile you're going
out on an operation does that,
that must drive you guys crazy more
than anything else that's sort of the
political elite that often have no idea
what's happening on the ground that are
just spouting off stuff.
For sure, for sure,
but as I said,
it's you listened to it but you can
only pay so much attention to it.
There's so much other things to focus on.
I mean
you think about it a little bit,
but you're not caught up in the 24 hour
news cycle like you know like people
contend to do here in America because
you're working and you're getting back
from one operation,
you're preparing for another operation.
I've got guys in the field,
I got another element in the field.
I'm going in the field. It's, you don't
have time to be sitting around, hey,
I wonder what this politician is
saying about what we're doing,
how much you have of
leadership that you brought to,
it was just about managing
stress for your guys.
Just making sure that they were
actually okay in the midst of the chaos.
You absolutely you have to do.
Some of that. I mean it's, it's a,
it's a balancing act between all kinds.
There's all kinds of things that you're
trying to juggle at the same time.
And managing stress on the
guys is definitely one of them.
And in a situation where you're getting
guys wounded and your guys are getting
killed, that stress meter can
get pegged out pretty quick.
So you have to manage it.
You have to do it to the best ability.
That's it's, it's hard.
It's hard to, because
the war is going to keep going
and you are going to keep you,
you have work that needs to continue.
So the stress is going to build up on,
on the troops.
And it's different for
every guy. You know, the,
the front line seal or soldier or marine,
they're worried about getting blown up.
They're worried about
getting shot and killed.
They're worried about their
friends getting shot and killed.
friends getting blown up.
And when you're in charge of
a bunch of guys you're in,
you're worried about all those
guys and that happening to them.
You're worried about if we make a mistake,
if we do something wrong,
if we cause some massive collateral damage
that has a negative strategic impact,
like not you have all those stresses
and you know, to control stress,
what do you do that it's like you look
at the things you can control and the
things you can't control.
Yeah.
You focus on the things you can control
and the things that you can't control.
You do your best to mitigate and then you
don't worry about them because they'll
drive you crazy. Yeah. What do you
make of sort of where we're at now,
having lived through the Iraq war,
like was it the right thing to do?
Should we have done things differently?
You should.
We have not just announced we were
leaving one day, the the whole,
the whole thing.
The whole thing is that hindsight is
2020 and any normal human being can look
back at the American history as a whole
and find out all the mistakes that we've
made, which are, you
know, infinite, right?
We make an infinite number of mistakes
and we do the best to try and repair
those once they've taken place.
So for me to look at it from that
angle, it's like, okay, yeah,
there's all kinds of mistakes
we make as a country.
We have make as a country and
we will make as a country.
But the best way for me to
kind of rationalize or not
even rationalize because I
don't think it needs rationalization,
but I,
when I look at it from a granular level,
which is,
which is very straightforward,
we went into a city,
the city of Ramadi that
was being controlled by
sick in surgeons do most sadistic,
evil,
subhuman people that you can imagine.
They were raping, torturing,
skinning people alive,
murdering whole families, beheading
people. And when we went in there,
and again I'm not talking about
we as this small group of seals,
I'm talking about when this massive force
of us coalition and Iraqi forces went
into that city and liberated those
people from the torturous and sadistic
control of those insurgents,
the people of Ramadi were overjoyed
and they would cheer when we killed in
surgeons. And they would tell
us where insurgents were.
And it was a beautiful
transition to watch.
And it didn't really take place until
after we left. But after we left,
we saw this. It was peaceful.
It was literally peaceful.
It went from a complete war zone to a,
to a peaceful city.
And where they were,
they had markets opened the street again,
they had kids going to school,
they had girls schools. Now,
there wasn't an in the city of
Ramadi was schools for girls.
And this was just unheard of while the
insurgence where they're trying to,
you know,
uh,
punish the populous with
their psychotic brand of,
of Al Qaeda Islam. Right. And, and the,
the people of Adi did
not want that at all.
And so from that perspective, it's
like, I go to sleep every night.